ja alles Weidel ist bei uns die
Bundessprecherin also die
Parteivorsitzende der AFD verweilt wenn
Sie jetzt auf diesen
Parteitag bzw europawahlversammlung
zurückblicken warum bekennt sich
eigentlich ihre Parteien nicht
unmissverständlich die EU in ihrer
jetzigen Form zu verlassen also einen
dexit eine Bewerberin hatte ja gesagt
jetzt sofort gleich
weil es nicht weil es nicht unsere
Programmatik entspricht wir streben im
Zielbild an Europa der Interessen und
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft an also eine
Kompetenz zurückverlagerung insgesamt
von Gesetzgebungsverfahren in die
nationalen Parlamente dort wo die
gewählten Volksvertreter auch sitzen und
eine Kompetenz Ausweitung in Gebieten wo
es auch Sinn macht das haben wir auch
hier ganz klar formuliert beispielsweise
in der gemeinsamen Formulierung den
gemeinsamen europäischen Formulierung
von gemeinsamen sicherheits- und
verteidigungsinteressen
die Europäische Union ist ein
völkerrechtsubjekt mit Verträgen
abgesichert das müssen sie zerschlagen
bevor Sie eine solche Wirtschafts- und
Interessensgemeinschaft Gründen können
wir haben das ja ganz ganz klar
beleuchtet dass eine Europäische Union
die weitreichend in die Kompetenzen und
in die Souveränität der Nationalstaaten
eingereicht dass diese reformiert werden
muss und das ist unser Zielbild das habe
ich übrigens bereits 2016 geschrieben
und auch gesagt dass unser Zielbild
eigentlich eine Europäische
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft sein muss einer
ihrer wichtigsten Verbündeten in Europa
Viktor Orban wird es aber sicherlich
ganz anders sehen denn er profitiert ja
von den Fleischtöpfen der Union der
Europäischen Union für seine agrarhilfen
für seine Umgehungsstraße der wird Ihnen
da keine Unterstützung gewähren
und das weiß ich nicht das müssen sie
Herrn Herrn Orban selbst fragen das wäre
auch jetzt anmaßend zu sagen was Herr
Orban darüber denken würde was mich
interessiert was die AFD interessiert
wir machen Politik für Deutschland
gerade deswegen weil die Fleischtöpfe
von denen ich gerade Rede von denen
besonders Ungarn und Polen profitieren
ja vor allen Dingen von deutschen
Steuerzahlern befüllt werden darum auch
der kompetenzrückbau wir müssen das
gesamte teure Gebilde Europäische Union
zurückbauen und dahin zurückführen
wo sie Sinn macht und das ist eine
europäische Interessen und
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft so wie es
ursprünglich vorgesehen war de Gaul das
Europa der Vaterländer das ist unser
Zielbild aber man muss sich dann in
Zukunft das Geld irgendwo anders her
besorgen jetzt fällt ja übrigens auch
auf dass fast alle deutschen
Wirtschaftsverbände vor der AFD warnen
das kann sich nicht kalt lassen als
frühere finanzmanagerin von JP Morgan
und der Bank of China
wer ist finanzmanagerin sie waren doch
nein sie waren das früher gewesen sie
haben ja bei diesen beiden Firmen
gearbeitet aber wenn die Wirtschaft die
ja auch global orientiert ist sagt wir
waren in vor der AFD deren Vorsitzende
sie sind kann sie das nicht kalt lassen
ich möchte das gerne korrigieren da
besteht ein Missverständnis ich war eine
Liste bei Goldman Sachs und ich habe die
Bank of China beraten aber vielleicht
dahin gehen noch mal zu den zu den
Wirtschaftsverbänden sie wissen
natürlich auch dass die
Wirtschaftsverbände so wie sie heute
aufgestellt sind natürlich auch
parteipolitisch durchsetzt sind dort
haben sie viele Vertreter auch mit einem
Parteibuch nicht von der AFD die dann
natürlich auch warten gegen unsere
Programmatik aber ich glaube dass wir
die Wirtschaftsverbände langfristig
überzeugen können von unserer
Programmatik denn wir sind die einzige
Partei die eine vernünftige Energie
Steuer Finanz und Währungspolitik
vertritt die die anderen Parteien
überhaupt gar nicht mehr vertreten die
Diskussion heute zeigt auch dass der
Widerstand gegen die Mitgliedschaft der
Bundesrepublik in der AFD eigentlich
immer stärker wird wie lange können Sie
denn da noch den Deckel auf dem Topf
halten da gibt es überhaupt nichts auf
den Topf zu halten wir haben das ja hier
auch diskutiert uns geht es darum klar
zu formulieren dass die NATO heute und
das sehen wir im ukrainekrieg zu einem
Sicherheitsrisiko für Europa geworden
ist und da sagen wir ganz klar wir
müssen als Europäer deutlich und
gemeinsam wir Europäer müssen gemeinsam
deutlich stärker unsere Interessen
innerhalb der NATO formulieren die ja
ganz anders gelagert sind als sie
Interessen der USA und das würden wir
uns wünschen und das muss auch
ausdiskutiert werden das ist im übrigen
auch die Linie von den manuell macron
das heißt aber die NATO Mitgliedschaft
steht für sie nicht zu Disposition
nein
Position es ist noch etwas anderes
aufgefallen hier bei den Reden der
Bewerberinnen und Bewerber für die
Kandidatenliste zur Wahl zum
Europäischen
Parlament viele dieser Rednerinnen und
Redner die haben kein gutes Haar
gelassen an der sogenannten
LGBT Community das heißt also das
Bekenntnis zur sexuellen Vielfalt das
würde angeblich unsere Kinder gefährden
wenn Sie das hören fühlen sie sich da
auch in Ihrem persönlichen ihrem eigenen
Lebensentwurf ständig bloßgestellt nein
überhaupt nicht weil ich kritisiere das
selbst also diese ganze gender Agenda
ist hochgradig schädlich für Kinder die
und auch für Jugendliche weil es ja auch
beinhaltet dass man per anklamation sein
Geschlecht auswählen kann ich glaube
diese Diffusität ist ungesund und ich
würde das auch für meine eigenen Kinder
nicht wollen und dementsprechend würde
ich das gerne trennen die gleich
Befestigung von homosexuellen Paaren und
von der ganzen gender Ideologie Weg das
wird immer permanent in einen Topf
geworfen und ich glaube die ganze
Diskussion muss man trennen weil sie
viele
viele Homosexuelle haben die das
ebenfalls ablehnen und vor allen Dingen
ist das auch übergriffig in die
Lebensweise von uns so von homosexuellen
Paaren und da merke ich immer wieder wie
solche gender Propheten weit weg von der
Lebenswirklichkeit sind die eigentlich
mit meiner Lebenswirklichkeit und meiner
Partnerin und unserer Familie nichts zu
tun haben dass sie Performance die
manche
afd-parteifreundinnen und Freunde von
ihnen da verlautbaren lassen die lehnen
sie ab
wie meinen Sie das das meine ich also
weil hier der Eindruck entstanden ist
das sei sozusagen ein Feindbild
Community hier für viele in der AFD
ich habe es ja gerade gesagt es fehlt
halt durcheinander geworfen schauen Sie
das ist das Problem immer wenn wenn
dumme Leute in der Regierung sind und
Politik machen es wird alles überreizen
alles überzogen und das Ziel die
Gleichberechtigung das ist doch schon
lange erfüllt aber es wird permanent
überzogen mit irgendwie zum gender Gaga
was ich für meine Kinder auch nicht
haben will ich möchte nicht dass
irgendjemand in die Schulen reingeht
bezahlt vom Staat und meinen Kindern
irgendwie erzählt dass sie vielleicht
auch eine Frau sein können ich möchte
das nicht dass in die Familien
eingegriffen wird von staatlicher Seite
und das hat mit der Gleichberechtigung
von Homosexuellen überhaupt gar nichts
zu tun und das wird auch von unserer
Partei getrennt
soweit alles Weiden die Bundessprecherin
der AFD bedanke mich für das Interview
so